can a matrix be multiplied with a number
can this matrix be multiplied with say 3
is this mathematically possible yes it
is possible to get the resulting matrix
each element of the matrix is multiplied
with this number let's see what the
resulting matrix looks like the order of
the resulting matrix will be the same as
the order of the original matrix the
original matrix is of the order 2 by 2
so the resulting matrix will also be of
the same order to get the 1 winnette
element of the resulting matrix we
multiply the 1 1 @ element of the
original matrix by 3 we get 2 multiplied
by 3 to get the 1 to 8 element of the
resulting matrix we multiplied the 1 to
earth element of the original matrix by
3 the 1 to earth element is 4 so we
write 4 multiplied by 3 here now I want
you to pause the video and find the
elements in these two positions we will
have minus 5 x 3 here and 1 x 3 here
finding each element is easy now 2 times
3 is 6 4 times 3 is 12 minus 5 times 3
is minus 15 and 1 x 3 is 3 this is the
answer 3 times this matrix gives us this
matrix this always works when a matrix
is multiplied by a constant if a matrix
is multiplied by a constant K then each
of its elements are multiplied by K to
get the resulting matrix this is an
important concept and it's called the
scalar multiplication multiplying a
matrix with a number is called scalar
multiplication can we find the negative
of a given matrix let's say we have a 2
by 2 matrix led how do we find - a pause
the video and think
about how you can find the negative of
matrix Z it's easy if you were able to
apply the concept we used - that can be
written as minus 1 multiplied by Z we
are multiplying a matrix with a constant
and this is a classic case of scalar
multiplication it's equal to minus 1
multiplied by this matrix Z let's shift
the camera a bit and write down the
resulting matrix underneath each element
will be multiplied with minus 1 1 will
be multiplied with minus 1 then 3 will
be multiplied with minus 1 and the last
two elements will also be multiplied
with minus 1 now we just need to solve
the expressions in each of the positions
to get the final matrix 1 multiplied
with minus 1 is minus 1 3 times minus 1
is minus 3 minus 5 multiplied with minus
1 is 5 and 2 times minus 1 is minus 2 if
that is this matrix then negative of Z
will beat this matrix